creo que estamos en el momento perfecto
para jugar un poco con la fórmula de la
varianza para ver si podemos encontrar
alternativas o formas de aprender nos
mejor esa fórmula la idea va a ser tomar
la fórmula de la varianza y usando un
poco de álgebra ver a dónde podemos
llegar
si nosotros recordamos habíamos denotado
a la varianza con las letras sigma
elevada al cuadrado y la fórmula decía
lo siguiente primero fijémonos en todos
los datos cada uno de los datos era un x
subíndice y entonces a xy le quitábamos
la media o el promedio de todos los
datos ya esta diferencia la elevamos al
cuadrado y después nos tomábamos la suma
de todos los datos es decir desde igual
a uno hasta n iv a todo esto lo
dividimos entre la cantidad de datos es
decir entre n y bueno ya que tenemos
esta fórmula vamos a jugar un poco con
ella a ver qué pasa cuando elevamos x
subíndice y menos elevado al cuadrado
bueno pues esto es la suma desde igual a
n de x y menos elevado al cuadrado pero
quién es esto bueno esto es x subíndice
y elevado al cuadrado y después esto es
un binomio cuadrado perfecto si se
acuerdan de cómo hacerlo en álgebra de
todas maneras si no se acuerdan vamos a
ponerlo aquí tal vez sea un poco confuso
que tengamos x subíndice y new pero pues
esto es lo mismo que x subíndice y menos
mil por equis subíndice y menos 1000 x
subíndice y menos mí o al cuadrado es lo
mismo que esto que tenemos aquí y bueno
primero tenemos x subíndice y al
cuadrado menos dos veces el primero por
el segundo es decir dos veces x
subíndice y por mí esto es porque
tenemos una vez x subíndice y
multiplicando a mí y otra vez yo
multiplicando a x subíndice
es decir menos 2 veces x y por mí y
bueno a esto hay que agregarle el tercer
término que es menos newport menos view
que va a ser ni un cuadrado entonces es
x subíndice y al cuadrado menos 2 veces
x subíndice y por mí
más cuadrada recuerden que estos tres
términos salen del binomio cuadrado
perfecto o en su dado caso de la
multiplicación de x subíndice y menos
por equis subíndice y menos mil muy bien
y ahora si nos fijamos en esta suma que
yo tengo aquí
esta suma que yo tengo aquí es lo mismo
que la suma de cada uno de los términos
es decir la suma de estos tres sumandos
es la suma de cada uno de los sumandos
por lo tanto yo lo puedo escribir de la
siguiente manera
no voy a tomar aquí aquí arriba no mejor
de voy a tomar aquí abajo como la suma
desde iu igual a uno hasta n del primer
término que es x subíndice y elevado al
cuadrado x subíndice y elevado al
cuadrado ya esto hay que quitarle la
suma desde igual a uno hasta n y aquí de
esa cuenta que hay dos constantes tanto
el 2 como el amigos son constantes
porque no tienen nada que ver con la
suma que se está haciendo con respecto a
y por ejemplo si yo sacara los primeros
términos tendrían menos 2 newport x 1
- 2000 por x2 y al final tanto el 2 como
el mío nunca cambian entonces todas las
constantes pueden salir de las sumas y
de hecho ahorita que estoy hablando de
sumas y designa la anotación de sigma me
recuerda mucho a los vídeos que hice de
cálculo donde yo hablaba de la integral
y es que tiras recuerdan que la integral
es una suma de partes muy muy muy
pequeñas y por eso les ponemos al lado
un de equis y también en esta ocasión
hablábamos de la notación sigma sin
embargo no me quiero meter mucho en
cálculo porque no estamos viendo cálculo
y yo lo único que quiero decirles es que
el segundo término me va a quedar como
menos dos veces mío por la suma desde
igual a uno hasta n y ahora sí de quien
del término x y del término x subíndice
y bueno por último tengo y bueno darse
cuenta que en mí o cuadrada es una
constante entonces la podemos sacar de
la suma me va a quedar mí o cuadrada que
multiplica a la suma desde igual a 1
n de que me va a quedar adentro pues me
queda un 1 porque si yo tengo 1 y lo
multiplicó por mí o cuadrada me va a
quedar view cuadrada y bueno ahora vamos
a simplificar todo esto esto es igual a
voy a bajar el pizarrón porque ya no me
cabe y bueno ahora que se podrá hacer
con estas tres sumas en la primera suma
tengo la suma desde igual a uno hasta
ndx subíndice y al cuadrado y sabemos
cuánto es eso bueno de hecho lo viaje
primero así y ahorita pensamos si
podemos saber expedientes pero esperen
aquí me faltaba una n ahorita está
acordando de que me falta una n este de
aquí arriba es lo mismo que este que
tengo aquí sin embargo hay que dividirlo
entre n para que sea la varianza
entonces todo esto hay que dividirlo
entre n hasta el final voy a dividir
entre n para no confundirme para no
confundirme más que tenemos una división
entre n entonces vamos a regresar a lo
que estábamos tengo las sumas desde iu
igual a 1 hasta el de x subíndice y al
cuadrado menos dos veces new que
multiplica al as
esta estamos esta horrible es mejor está
así muy que multiplica a la suma desde
igual a uno hasta n de x subíndice y ya
esto hay que aumentarle y quien es la
tercera suma la suma desde igual a uno
hasta n de 1 bueno pues esto es lo mismo
que tener uno más uno más uno más uno
más uno el de veces y si se dan cuenta
11 11 n veces es lo mismo que uno y no
esperen que es lo mismo que n por lo
tanto tendría yo n que multiplica a mu
cuadrada entonces esta suma es n y
multiplicada por muy cuadrada me queda
simple y sencillamente más muy cuadrada
que multiplica a n ok pero recuerden que
todo esto era el numerador de la
varianza me falta dividirlo todo entre n
ahorita lo divido entre n primero vamos
a fijarnos en esto y que puedo ser yo
aquí bueno en el 1er
sumando tengo la suma de xy al cuadrado
creo que nada en el segundo tengo menos
dos muy
por todo esto y hoy a télam ya lo tengo
esperen esperen lo que quiero hacer es
otra vez voy a regresar a la en el aire
que estaba dividiendo que habíamos
dejado en la parte de arriba
recuerden que esta era la parte de
arriba de mi división es decir en mi
numerador pero abajo teníamos todo
dividido entre n por lo tanto ahora sí
voy a ocupar esa n esto todo esto había
que dividirlo entre n y como n dividía a
los tres suman 2 entonces n divide a
cada uno de los tres suman 2 esté entre
n este de aquí entre n y este de aquí
entre n y bueno en el primero no podemos
hacer mucho tengo la suma desde igual a
uno hasta ndx y elevado al cuadrado
entre n entonces lo voy a dejar simple y
sencillamente tal cual esto es la suma
desde igualdad uno hasta ndx subíndice y
elevado al cuadrado entre n y en el
segundo término tengo menos 2 new que
multiplica a y aquí tengo algo muy
importante tengo la suma desde igualdad
uno hasta ndx y
n qué es eso bueno todo esto de aquí es
ni más ni menos que la media en efecto
están en lo correcto la media porque la
suma de todos los datos
/ / n es la media es decir mucho y si yo
tengo mucho que multiplica a 2 no me
queda 2 muy cuadrada entonces esto se
simplifica a menos 2 muy cuadrada y esto
vaya que sí fue una buena simplificación
porque nos dimos cuenta que todo esto
que teníamos aquí era la media y bueno
en el tercer sumando tengo en la que
multiplica tiene que divide entonces se
pueden ir y solamente me queda muy
cuadrada vamos simplificando bastante
bien este ejercicio y bueno ahora que
tengo del primero no puedo hacer mucho
porque porque tengo los cuadrados y me
queda la suma desde y igual a uno hasta
n de x subíndice y elevado al cuadrado
aquí no se puede hacer mucho dividido
entre n todo esto había que dividirlo
entre n y bueno después tengo menos muy
cuadrada más muy cuadrada pues aquí se
va una mutua
me queda solamente menos muy cuadrada y
ya están tenemos una nueva forma de
escribir a la varianza acabamos de
encontrar una segunda fórmula
alternativa para la varianza la cual
podemos utilizar según los datos que
tengamos y dice lo siguiente tomen la
suma de todos los cuadrados de cada uno
de los datos tomamos la suma de todos
los cuadrados de cada uno de los datos
lo dividimos entre la cantidad de datos
ya esto le quitamos la media elevado al
cuadrado y de donde salió esta fórmula
pues salió de la fórmula original de
varianza y utilizando un poco de álgebra
hicimos este binomio al cuadrado
perfecto y después separamos las sumas y
dividimos todo entre n solamente
utilizamos un poco de álgebra y
encontramos una fórmula alternativa o si
lo quieren ver así como una fórmula un
poco más pulida en el aspecto de que si
tenemos nosotros la media es muy fácil
calcular esta fórmula y bueno si
quisiera yo escribir todo en términos de
xy pues entonces tengo que pasar la
media en términos de x
para encontrar una tercera fórmula
alternativa la media es igual a la suma
desde igual a uno hasta n de todos los x
y todo esto hay que dividirlo entre n
así si yo sustituyó a esta media en mi
fórmula alternativa que había sacado
puedo encontrar otra fórmula otra forma
de escribir esta varianza entonces esto
es lo mismo que quien pues primero tengo
la suma desde x y desde igual a 1 hasta
en de x y elevada al cuadrado
y todo esto dividido entre n y después
tengo menos la media elevado al cuadrado
pero la media es todo esto de aquí
entonces si yo sustituyó voy a obtener
que es muy cuadrada o dicho de otra
manera es la suma desde igual a uno
hasta ndx y todo esto elevado al
cuadrado
la suma desde igual a uno hasta ndx y
todo esto
cuadrado / pues en el elevado al
cuadrado porque el cuadrado de una
división es el cuadrado del numerador
entre el cuadrado del denominador y
darse cuenta que esta fórmula que estoy
sacando de nuevo nos sirve cuando no
tenemos la media ya dada es decir si no
tenemos la media en lugar de calcular la
media y después elevarla al cuadrado
podemos utilizar la tercera fórmula
alternativa que solamente depende de x y
ya mí en lo personal me gusta más la
segunda fórmula sin embargo creo que la
tercera fórmula es muy útil si no
tenemos al promedio es decir si no
tenemos en la media solamente ponemos
todos los datos y con mucho cuidado
resolvemos esta operación pero al final
lo más importante es que tú te sientas
cómodo con alguna de estas tres fórmulas
eso ya depende de ti lo que sí quiero
que veamos es que las tres fórmulas
salieron de utilizar pura álgebra es
decir con puro conocimiento de álgebra
llegamos de la primera fórmula a la
segunda fórmula y sustituyendo a la
media llegamos a la tercera fórmula de
hecho algunos libros de texto lo que te
dicen es la fórmula de la varianza es y
ponen la primera
y además 3 como alternativa la segunda y
como otra alternativa la tercera fórmula
espero que todo esto haya sido de tu
agrado y hayas entendido bien de dónde
salieron cada una de las cosas porque
así ya tienes tres formas alternativas
de escribir a la varianza por lo pronto
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo